my wife had been home already for a few
hours crying and literally hungry and in
that moment I was like oh my gosh I'm
about to relive all of my parents
Financial nightmares where they're
constantly stressed and fighting about
money I suck as a human being I don't
know how to provide and let my best
friend down I feel like this big of a
man that was a really sucky moment for
me but it was also one where I made a
different decision too because I poured
a lot of negativity into my soul but I
also decided I am going to do whatever
it takes to never be in this situation
again and four and a half years I was
financially independent
all right guys bang bang I've got Chris
here with me Chris I thought a great
place to start would be in the real
estate market uh you are well known as a
real estate investor as a coach as a
mentor what do you think the biggest
mistakes people make when they set off
on this kind of real estate investing
Journey there's tons of people who know
majority of the millionaires in the
United States of America made it in real
estate one of the big mistakes that
people could avoid to help them just
increase the probability of success in
that asset class man we talk about real
estate we could talk about business we
could talk about personal life we could
talk about message marriage and it's
always the same mess Everyone is always
lone wolfing it they're basically just
intuitively thinking that they have what
it takes and that is always the slowest
path to achieve anything is just
assuming that you know so if you're
going to invest in the game of Real
Estate you can do the typical Mom and
Pop shop thing you can go it alone you
can say I read a book or two and now I'm
good to go and I'm like well I don't
know if that's going to produce your
best results think about that there's 30
major strategies in all of real estate
and what are you gonna do try a flip try
to wholesale a deal you're gonna try to
buy an apartment complex and you're
coming into this with no experience and
so sometimes your your learning
experience is enough to kill you
financially but people don't really get
that and so it's just bizarre to me I'm
like why does why don't more people
understand that if you're gonna go and
expect greatness do something where you
want to make a big splash you gotta
surround yourself with people of
experience that have been there and done
that because it's almost like the
biggest rip-off strategy on the planet
it's the ultimate shortcut which is just
literally don't reinvent the wheel just
get in proximity to people that know
what they're doing and then copy them
and literally just follow them step by
step because I'd rather follow someone
that's done it you know a thousand times
like take single-family real estate I've
done two billion dollars worth 6 500
projects over the last 20 years at this
point I invest in the top five markets
out of 324 and I've made my mistakes
like the first time I went and bought
out of state real estate it was a
nightmare I lost a million dollars on
186 properties after 2008 that I thought
I had bought right turned out I was 100
wrong but today I've gone on to buy now
literally over 6 000 out-of-state
properties and I've learned how to like
maximize my Roi so you can literally
learn from me watch a guy like me and
have way more success or you can just do
the the prideful stubborn and all I'll
do it all by myself name so when you
think about this idea of surrounding
yourself with people who've done it
before getting proximity to people who
have experience what is that normal
conversation in your career is it
something where you go to them and you
say hey I need a mentor is it you go to
them and you say hey I want to be a real
estate investor you're a real estate
investor let me try to learn from you
and kind of Shadow you day to day like
what does that actually look like from a
practical standpoint as people go down
this path of trying to get around
successful people and learn from them
yeah so there is this world of coaches
and mentors and then there's a world of
successful people and they're often not
the exact same thing so there's a lot of
people who have great success but they
actually can't reverse engineer and tell
you exactly how they do it because it's
just not their calling in life they're
just too busy Building Wealth they can't
tell you what they're doing but on the
other extreme you've got people that
love to teach and don't do the world is
filled with all of these all of these
fake people that oh yeah I bought three
Deals and now I I'm a marketer so I
teach hundreds of people how to do what
I've done only this little bit and what
I'm actually looking for is someone
who's relevant in the game today and
what that means is my standards they
have to have at least achieved 10 times
more than the epitome of what I hope to
so for example if I want to be worth
nine figures 100 million dollars then I
got to be training with the billionaire
someone that's got 10 times that result
and they've got to be actively in the
game today it's kind of like what I want
to train with Michael Jordan today or or
what I want to train with Michael Jordan
1998 and for me it's like I want the
dude that is that crushed it but is
still crushing it today and number three
actually has some type of system or
pathway or Mastermind or I can freaking
write a check something to get into
their airspace enough that I can learn
it directly from the horse's mouth and
as you're going through this process
right so I love this idea of finding
people who are 10 times as successful as
you want to be and also people who are
actively doing it at the moment and able
to deliver those practical uh kind of
details that really is where a lot of
the value comes from what is that
conversation like how much of it do you
think people can get out of being like
hey here's a deal I'm looking at uh what
do you think versus hey I just want to
watch how you do a deal and I'll kind of
just learn through osmosis yeah so let's
talk about the most light-hearted
version of that I read their book the
book doesn't talk back the book doesn't
answer questions I love reading but I do
not mistake books for mentors then you
go a little further if this person has
for example some type of Mastermind
sometimes you gotta stroke a check to be
in the room and that doesn't mean that
they're helping you that just means that
you're in their airspace to actually
learn from them if you go to the
furthest extreme what I actually look
for whenever possible is partnership how
do I get you vested in my success and it
might be uh I'll do all the work I'll
put up the resources I'll put up the
whatever and as long as you're like on
my team and we're sharing in the
winnings together that's where you can
almost guarantee the highest and best
outcome so for example
um you know after I made my Big Splash
in real estate and I've automated my
systems and I'm buying houses literally
every day right now but I spend an hour
a month on it like I have a team doing
all that I've graduated I'm not the
operator I'm the owner now I'm in the
game of private equity and so for
example Roland Fraser literally has
helped participate it in 1 000 different
mergers and Acquisitions and exit
and Roland and I are now Partners on 27
different companies together and that
means that he's vested every time I need
something I call him I text him and he's
there he shows up he brings resources to
the table and I'm achieving a much
higher level of business outcome with
Roland than without now he's got a
consult for Equity model where he
basically I I give him 10 of the company
but I get a hundred percent of his
brains whenever I need it he's not an
active employee he's not that kind of
partner but that 10 of his mental
bandwidth and experience is enough for
me to trade 10 for a thousand X growth
and so that's another example of oh I
got to find out how to literally catch a
tiger by the tail get the most
successful person I can and find a way
to literally stretch your deals together
so you've got a very unique way of
viewing uh kind of how people can find
success get around the right people uh
but you're actively doing this yourself
what's your daily schedule like you got
a lot of things going on you own a bunch
of different companies like what does
your daily schedule look like
so I I don't believe that time is
required
to create outcome because I used to be
that 80 hundred hour a week entrepreneur
many many years ago I'm married I got
four kids and I felt totally out of
balance in my life and uh many years ago
I had my best friend die in a
paragliding accident and he left his
widowed wife and four little baby boys
back on Earth and I remember after that
I thought why
am I killing myself and working so hard
because what if today were my last day
and I said okay this is gonna be weird
there's gonna be a stretch for you Mr
100 Hour Week dude what would your
ultimate schedule look like like
um what what's perfect because I know
like I wake up at 4am I got two hours in
the gym every day I love that I got a
bodybuilding competition coming up in
seven weeks last year I took second I'm
pissed this year I'm taking first I'm
going to do my best so I got goals there
I got goals with my wife everything
that's important is done by 9 A.M in the
morning and when we kind of talk about
my typical schedule it's kind of weird
because here's what my perfect life
currently looks like
on Mondays I produce videos for the game
of influence
Tuesday and Thursday I work on my
businesses from home Wednesday all day
is my wife's day we spend all day
together we'll take our jet we'll fly
somewhere we'll hang out we'll do
something something that builds us
Friday is my kids day all my kids are
privately educated we bring teachers
into our home we got four people that
basically
create this custom education for them
Saturday is my day Sunday is God's day
so for me my perfect is working about 25
to 30 hours a week and if I work twice
as much
I might be able to make more money I
don't believe so I think I would be less
happy I think I'd be more stressed and
so I don't really think success is a
function of time I think it's a function
of understanding your value and then
also balancing that against what is your
perfect because all of us should be
striving for our ideal in our
relationships and our health and also in
our finances and I've been living that
schedule for years now and that one it
works for me if I work more than 35
hours I get cranky if I work less than
20 hours I'm not creating enough 25 30
hours is kind of my jam and for me I
like to block that so it's not just a
little bit every day it's like uh-uh
when I'm in I'm 100 present and I'm
working on this thing I'm having a board
meeting pull people in we're causing
we're creating we're doing something and
when I'm not I'm out I'm fully present
in some other game of life that is
designed to produce other utility other
happiness other Joy other fulfillment so
let's talk about the impact on the
businesses how many businesses do you
think that you are an owner of or kind
of actively operating alongside right
now uh over 400 companies right now okay
and are all of these in the real estate
slash investment and you know including
uh other types of content like what
would the buckets be of those 400
companies yeah so you've got everything
ranging so I have an intention and a
goal over the next decade to own
companies in every industry
um because I'm building towards being
The entrepreneur's Economist I'm going
to be the most valuable human being on a
planet on the planet a decade from now
that can literally advise in any
industry which means that you know
currently I've got um tech companies uh
I've got restaurants a variety of
different franchises health and medical
spas definitely my fair share of real
estate any financial planner would say
I'm probably out of balance with so much
of that going on
um so it's really uh it's really a
variety and I use this idea of fractal
geometry uh in running my businesses
it's this idea in in nature that if you
take a tree and extract a branch the
branch like a tree if you extract a twig
it looks like a tree if you take a leaf
it actually under a microscope looks
like a tree and on and on so in my world
I've got a present of the board that
runs you know X number of companies
those people report to the other
companies and basically everything flows
down in this business geometry and I can
in two board meetings a month and about
eight hours a month I can run all of my
companies so of those 400 how what is
like the biggest one maybe and then what
is one that you're like hey we have it
it is a business but we spend almost no
time on like give us kind of the example
of the two different extremes on that
Spectrum yeah well you're actually
bringing up pomp a really good point
which is what is the goal and um I'm
going to hit this a little bit sideways
if I can for a moment because you got a
lot of people out there that are
entrepreneurs and what they do is they
traded a job for their business and what
they did is they went from one stream of
income to another stream of income but
the problem is they have a stream and
some businesses have huge potential but
honestly sometimes we get to a point
where it's like wow I maximized my
market cap my potential what I can do or
I can't bring more to it and so most
entrepreneurs fail to graduate and
graduate means you Empower an executive
director a CEO somebody to run it for
you so that you reclaim your time and on
the second go around pick a bigger
business pick a bigger space take all
your experience and do it bigger and
better after that second one and you get
a CEO in place then you're gonna want
eight more because you're going to learn
that you don't have to bootstrap anymore
you have resources that you can borrow
or get to self-fund you can start with
the CEO from day one you don't graduate
to one and that's that's when all of a
sudden the whole world opened up to me
where it's like wow
um the most intelligent approach to
business is the one that doesn't need
you I start the party I find I bring the
people together I collect them collate
them I get them organized I get them
producing that business has six months a
year or two to do what it's supposed to
do or I take it out in the back of the
shed and shoot it and just start iterate
again and most entrepreneurs don't
understand that their most powerful
Creations will not be on their first
second of their business it'll be on
their fourth fifth sixth and seventh so
the goal is to have a system to iterate
to not become so attached to your own
core business so with that in mind my
real estate that kicked off this whole
party
um every year I add hundreds of new
doors to my portfolio and my system is
on Monday I shoot a bunch of social
media people from around the world
millions of people every week watch me
they look at my vast and Growing
Experience in real estate they come into
my sales department decide if they're
going to partner with me they put up the
asset sets and there's this whole system
that runs and operates independent of me
that basically builds portfolios for
people where 50 50 owners that business
takes me about an hour a month and with
an hour that whole thing is really hands
off now that's a really ideal scenario
to get to but if we go to The Other
Extreme this last year we've launched
half a dozen companies or acquired
companies that have billion dollar
potential one of them is actually a
master franchise company that creates
franchises for companies where we
actually Vet companies set them up for
franchise and then take the very best
ones negotiate some equity and then we
do the marketing for them and sell the
franchises and and blast them off one of
the companies um in there that we
launched is called property and it's
actually a real estate franchise that
I'm partnered with on Carlos Reyes where
we are actually combining the power of
wholesaling for people that want to make
a couple million dollars a year
wholesaling and all of my Buy and Hold
strategies so that you know after every
number of wholesale deals and flips
you're also acquiring and you're
actually getting the longevity the
long-term play wall having an absolute
killer active income you know that will
probably be sold out in a two to three
year spans it'll be a hundred million
dollars in sales to onboard all the
people for that and that's designed in
royalties to produce about a hundred
million dollars a year uh just yesterday
we pointed our CEO for that company our
pre-launches in two months our official
launch is in June and we've got all the
components that we need that one I'm
probably gonna put in a couple hours a
week
for the next couple of months and once
it's something going I'm basically going
to be playing a board of directors role
and um I will on that one you know
because of some of my expertise I'll be
doing a little bit more social media for
it uh when we have conventions I'll I'll
be booked to speak at those conventions
and then we're gonna have you know our
leadership uh franchise training modules
so I'll participate probably once or
twice a month for an hour here or there
to share my perspective on how to
successfully run this franchise so that
one's going to be a little bit of a
heavier lift that's probably my heaviest
type of lift on that other extreme but
even there I'm not going to allocate on
average more than two three or four
hours a week that's the max that it gets
as it's going through its optimization
process
how do you pick the CEOs for all of
these businesses like what are you
looking for where do you find them how
do you compensate them how do you
incentivize them yeah so
this last year we started
um having a much higher need for vetted
CEOs and and it takes months to find the
right fit someone with the The
Experience Etc so last year we actually
launched a private in-house leadership
training program called CEO boot camp
and this is where we take our culture
and our companies it's something we do
that's a little bit weird
um is that all of my companies operate
under the same cultural environment and
so we've got a CREDO and approach to
business a way that we build business
and so you know if you were in Orem Utah
and you earned my 40 000 square foot
building you'd see a couple dozen
different companies all sitting together
and even though they have different
companies they're building and growing
there's a uh there's leadership training
that's this communal accounting we've
we've centralized a lot of our systems
and so what I'm now doing is we're going
out into the marketplace and we're
recruiting Talent potential CEOs and
basically they get to know us we say
we'll fly you in come check us out go
through CEO boot camp train with us
educate with us we got people paying 50
to 100 000 so that training we'll give
it to you for free and now it's an
incubator so we incubate our leadership
well in the advance of our needs uh two
days ago I pointed a new CEO yesterday
another one and on Monday I'm flying in
someone that might be a CEO I'm hoping
for my franchise company
and so um it we're trying to now start
the courting process months in advance
uh but depending on the company you know
um CEO salaries can range you know from
100 to 250 or 300 000 bonuses another
100 150 200 depending it just depends on
the company and the size the tech space
or what really what it's in and and
um I'm a huge believer in Talent density
which means I want to find top of Market
talent and not people that I hope end up
becoming great and I'm there first I
don't want with some companies you can
be my first if you were a successful
division leader a manager and we
promoted you cool that happens uh but
for some of these really big ones I I
like to find the most expensive people
that I can because they bring in the
most experience they've had you know
usually multiple eight-figure
nine-figure wins maybe even a 10 figure
win and those are the people that we
bring in to help build these companies
how do you screen those people for yes
they have experience ends but that they
will also be able to operate within a
startup environment right there's
something different between the Fortune
500 CEO having to go back and kind of
build a building from or a business from
scratch with two or three people those
are two very different types of roles
how do you screen for that yeah so what
we usually do is we we have multiple
interviews just to get to know them I
just had a call a few days ago with a
gentleman who had a nine figure exit as
last company this dude interviews so
well and the president of my board is
like Chris I need you to talk to this
dude because Tim he's either too good to
be true or he's real his resume is real
his Glassdoor reviews are real and as I
got to know him I got to throw some very
funky side fighter questions by him
because Mike my culture is built on
feedback candidness vulnerability
um a lot of organizations find that
taboo they won't go there so I actually
asked him a lot of vulnerable questions
I actually got hyper personal talked
about his personal life and he passed
that interview really really well
because he was willing there was no
resistance and he was having the kind of
conversations that people just normally
don't have I'm like okay we have a
personality fit we have a character fit
and we also look like we have a
professional fit let's fly them in after
we fly them in we'll investigate some of
our company options and then I'm
probably going to dump them into CEO
bootcamp and say hey come hang out with
us for the next several weeks or several
months and learn with us it's only going
to take a couple hours uh you know a
week and our hope is that as we grow
together and find philosophy together if
we have a match the moment we have
something that could be a fit we'll now
have an interview for that so all the
original interviews are not about a
company it's about down the road three
months six months a year from now we
might have a really impressive company
fit for you so what we're doing is
recording before there's an opportunity
usually and that creates an environment
where people don't have to impress more
than they should people can really take
the time to get to know each other and I
think with CEOs that's the best approach
what are some of the questions that you
would ask in that type of interview
where uh it's a little bit more probing
or a little bit more personal that
you're trying to really understand who
is this person
yeah I actually want to go to
in their childhood what was the most
difficult thing that you faced I'm gonna
find out real fast if they're willing to
be vulnerable or if they're going to be
you know they're going to tighten their
sphincter and they're going to pull back
a little bit and say hey can we keep
this professional can we just talk about
my career and I'm like actually for us
to embark on the journey that we're
going to our culture is actually built
on vulnerability and I need to see if
you can demonstrate the ability to get
personal like that and frankly if I find
people that can't I just don't want to
have anything to do with them because I
don't want just it there's a strong
attraction that people have to the
culture that we build and it's one of
personal growth our core foundational
philosophy is what you achieve in your
personal life is far more important than
what you'll ever professionally achieve
so are you finding fulfillment in your
health and in your relationships because
look at these babies when someone can't
keep a budget and financially they've
got problems or they just can't control
their spending when someone has
relationship problems and issues and
they just can't figure them out and when
someone is fat when someone doesn't
prioritize their health how does that
not impact your leadership in an
organization and it sounds a little bit
harsh maybe a little bit rude but the
reality is I'm looking for leaders that
can Inspire and if you've got a problem
with your health I'm sorry you're going
to struggle to inspire people and
they're going to be people judging that
book by its cover saying why should I
follow you you clearly are wearing all
of your problems on the outside it
doesn't mean people have to be perfect
but if they're willing to work on their
stuff that's attractive and people that
aren't that's unattractive so if there's
resistance it's just not going to be a
fit
how do you manage the businesses from
like an operational or financial like
reporting standpoint right so you've got
all these businesses I can only imagine
uh kind of the day-to-day of some of the
people who work with you uh what they
have to go through because there's
individual companies that I'm an
investor in that they struggle to figure
out you know what is the revenue in
stripe
where did that money go which bank
account like you know just the
complexity of one business now
multiplied by 400 what have you learned
there or are there certain systems or
processes that you all have put in place
that have really been helpful that other
people could learn from yeah so I find
that with every new startup with every
new company there's a bunch of decisions
that have to be met if you're going to
achieve success for example what is the
culture how are we going to tackle
accounting
um and I think by the way those two out
the gate are really important some other
ones are what is our system for
accountability uh are we using critical
drivers and kpis and so you know when
someone is a brand new business operator
they don't understand these things
they're literally I'm throwing out money
I'm hiring you to do stuff and then
we're going to figure things out but
after you've actually optimized the
business to the point where you know how
to get it to make money and you're
manipulating things to impact margin
expenses Etc you finally figure out how
to actually run business well so when we
start a company I never say hey let's
start from scratch again and see if we
can figure out culture and systems and
crms and management tools I'm like no
when we start a company you are going to
inherit our entire system so for example
my CFO his name is Tim weeks he owns a
company called company vitals and they
do fractional cfoing for companies and
when I started with them years ago it
was for a handful of my companies now
they provide 19 fractional CFOs for all
of my organizations well what that means
is our weekly reporting is is the same
our monthly financials are always
prepared at the same time so that our
CEOs and directors can review them our
quarterly reports all look the same and
everything is on the same system I am
you know there's people that look at me
like wow Chris you're like that real
estate guy that knows how to make you
know snap your fingers make money in
deals and I'm like actually I'm the
scale guy
which is if I have to repeat anything
one time
then it's worth building a system around
so that I never have to ever repeat ever
again I don't like to repeat what I say
I don't like to repeat words everything
that is manual should find a way to
achieve some level of automation so in
business we just we basically adopt our
our systems for automation
when you're doing this there's a lot of
other companies that reach very large
scale that have a bunch of different
philosophies uh one of them I'm thinking
about is the coke Industries business
one of you know first or second largest
private companies in America they have
this whole philosophy of good profit the
idea is they want to pursue profit that
is done not through regulatory capture
or kind of uh you know government
credits or anything like that they want
to pursue profit that is captured by
competing in the free market uh and you
only can do that by actually solving
customer problems is there some phrase
or some way that you talk about your
business philosophy that people can kind
of take away and say okay when I think
of Chris this is the business philosophy
that he's used to build these 400
companies yeah I think there's actually
two
um we live in a world where enlightened
capitalism is really being diminished
and what we have it's been replaced with
the selfish version of capitalism hey I
wanna my intention is to create this
company yeah yeah create value in the
world and then have this exit I'm gonna
make a grundle of money
and where that selfish is that the core
focus is not on your just cause uh Simon
sinek wrote a great book called The
Infinite game and he talks about this
enlightened capitalism where a company
has to be driven if you're gonna if you
die who's going to pick up the Baton and
continue the mission forward profits is
not a mission prophets is a goal
um you know Eli um Goldenrod wrote this
my favorite Business book called the
goal and basically the goal is your
profits and your margin and if you don't
learn how to do that well then you don't
get to stay in business very long so on
the one hand one of the missions has to
be yes we have to generate appropriate
margin profits for the success of the
business or else we don't have
sustainability
but that has to be balanced with your
mission what is your just cause what
cause is is powerful enough that people
want to work for you because people
don't want to work for you like wow you
guys are really profitable you're stable
sounds like a great company you're going
to attract professionals that are
basically looking for stability and
financial opportunity and I just think
that's weak I think there needs to be a
balance of who are you and what are you
about what is your cause and is it
inspiring enough to take people's breath
away does it cause them want to be with
you for example I I put on I own an
event center in Utah and five six times
a year people come in from the you know
mostly around the country and they'll
enjoy a four-day fully immersive event
where they experience powerful Financial
Training on real estate and private
equity and everything that that
multi-millionaires and billionaires are
doing and then I combine it with really
really powerful mindset training and
this stuff I mean we get crazy we're
doing glass walks firewalks we're
challenging our limiting beliefs it's a
space of incredible vulnerability it's
terrifying at first but all these
exercises I put people through
force them to make a choice either you
are or you're not about the personal
development thing because I'm what I'm
doing is I'm attracting a culture of
growth and find people that are so
committed to their personal growth in
life and that's who I want in my
companies so that is a place where we
display a part of our just cause which
is pouring into people literally I want
to promote everyone in my company and if
you're not an a player and you don't
seek promotion I don't want you on my
team literally I want you if you're
making 50 000 a year now I'm asking you
how do we get you at 100K how do we get
you to you know to to Serious six
figures why because if you're an
entrepreneur you've got to work with the
founder and the owners of the company
who want to pour into you that will want
to pay you for adding more value on this
planet so that you can save enough
meaningful money to be a professional
investor and say for my career I'm a
crazy successful entrepreneur
and I have enough financial success on
the outside that either way I get my
millions of dollars and I'm not replying
relying just on a single sole source of
income well in my crowd that's really
exciting and I don't just say it I mean
it I invest in them I give them access
to my investing tools for free when
they're a member of my team and and so
I've got people that work for me with
that are being encouraged have
businesses on the site and it means that
from time to time I lose really good
people
but I would rather lose people to a
better opportunity of them doing what
they're meant to do with their life than
just trying to control people most
corporations don't get that today
they're losing people because their
cause isn't just it's not worthy people
are feeling disconnected the the Mental
Health crisis is so out of whack and
companies don't know how to treat their
their people in a way where man they
think they had a hard time adjusting to
Millennials just wait gen Z is coming up
94 of them want entrepreneurship which
means if they get hired to work in your
company if you can't create a fun
stimulating exciting opportunity of
growth they're out and so corporations
they're I think they're in really big
trouble because we the the shift that's
coming is is so much bigger in tidal
wave size than you know the millennial
shift that we've had over the last
decade you mentioned earlier that uh
Monday is for all the content Tuesday
and Thursdays for the business Wednesday
is a day for you and your wife explain a
little bit as to what you guys do on
those Wednesdays and what are some of
the benefits uh and maybe even some of
the trade-offs that you've had to make
to make sure that Wednesdays you spend
with your wife hey guys I hope that
you're enjoying this conversation as you
probably realize we don't run any ads on
this show that's right all the other
podcasts all the other YouTube shows
that you watch they have advertisers we
don't have any direct relationships with
advertisers and we simply create this
because we enjoy doing it now that we do
that though we have a team and if you'd
like to support us one way you can do
that is to go subscribe to the pop
letter it's a daily letter that I write
to about 235 000 people about my
personal opinion on financial markets
business technology and Bitcoin just go
to pompletter.com and you can sign up
there I'd love to have you join us and
it's a great easy way to support the
work that the team and I are doing on a
daily basis alright let's get back into
this conversation
so imagine for a moment
that you had all the money on the planet
and you didn't need more and then the
question is are you happy
do you feel fulfilled
and often the pursuit of financial
success and fulfillment they don't go
hand in hand there's a limit there's a
limit to a perfect amount of work that
someone can gain from fulfillment from
but then that leaves a huge gap in the
rest of their life and everyone's a
little different I can't speak for
others but I can tell you that for me my
wife is my best friend we've been
married for 21 years and we just love
spending time together we love learning
new things together we love traveling
together we love experiencing the world
together we've been to more than 40
different countries together and we live
to have time for each other and um when
I realized that
it actually kind of backs up a little
earlier in the game because my wife and
I you know a decade ago we were only
traveling once a year we were taking
like that annual trip because I was too
busy working and doing other stuff
and I wanted to uh I was in I was in hot
water with my wife because I had made
some mistakes and I really wanted to
show her on this particular Christmas
that I was sorry so I wanted to make
something really sentimental for her and
this project uh uh you know was a
quilting project I enrolled her my
mother-in-law and I spent 500 hours
building this tapestry that was a symbol
of our love and our life and what we're
creating together and part of the
process was I had to find I wanted to uh
embroider it on the edges with a hundred
printed pictures on fabric of my
favorite life memories
and when I went through 10 000 pictures
at that time to find the top 100 moments
period
91 of the 100 were found traveling
and after I realized that I said we're
going to start traveling every month
we're gonna live to create these
memories we've brought our children on
that journey and
um
that's when we're at a routine and doing
what matters most to us for me to
experience balance in my life I live
to have time with my wife to connect
meaningfully to spend time with our kids
and just be with my best friend and so
you know the trade-off is my company
probably would love to have more time
with me but it forces me to value my
time differently and empower the right
kind of people that can keep things
growing without me
what do you do on those Wednesdays do
you just sit and talk do you guys go
visit like what are you actually doing
uh yeah no I mean we you know one of my
favorite things to do with our private
jet is to do a same-day teleportation in
and out
and so
um what that means is my my morning is a
sacred routine between exercise and
meditation and time with my wife and
kids but at nine o'clock that's all done
so we usually you know our Airport's 20
minutes away our our private and so you
know by 9 30 we're in the air
and the goal is to sleep in our own bed
and so you know one of our Wednesdays
this last year we went to Disneyland for
a day and we literally just lived it up
did the very best rides flew home slept
in her bed that was a blast
um and so my wife and I we um you know
we'll go teleport somewhere and go
experience a culture a people or
something fun sometimes it's a spa day
you know something local my wife is a
crazy I'd like to use the professional
word geologist but she is nuts about
crystals and rocks like crazy our house
is filled with them and so we'll we'll
go out to like Tucson to the big annual
gem show or in Denver in September we'll
do that one or we'll literally go rock
hounding in Oklahoma where we can pull
up big quartz crystals out of the ground
that stuff lights her up my wife and I
practiced this thing called spousal
advocacy and the game is she knows what
I want and I know what she wants and
whatever my wife wants I want it more
for her than she wants it herself what
we try to do is outdo each other and so
in the game you know sometimes at
Wednesday will be focused on her
sometimes it'll be focused on me and
that way we get to try different things
and the goal is to just support each
other's different approaches to life and
learn and grow together that's amazing
Friday you said you spend with your kids
what do you guys doing on Fridays you
know it's winter now and we got a lot of
snow we got last week we got dumped on
two and a half feet in a single day so
we'll go skiing together uh or there
will be some kind of outing
um you know Shenzhen that big Chinese
you know you know traveling show was
here last week uh the kids have a
Shakespearean module that they're going
through so in a couple of weeks you know
there's a Friday play that we're gonna
go to
um my wife and I when we got married we
decided wow you know if we are fortunate
enough to figure out how to become you
know financially well enough we'd love
to pull our kids out of the public
school system and we'd love to customize
their education and so we've been
experimenting with their kids I mean I I
don't know maybe a decade from now I'll
look back and say well I really messed
some things up because I don't believe
my kids need to know chemistry
trigonometry a whole bunch of useful
useless things that I was taught growing
up and instead I'm like what are you
good at what do you excel at and let's
spend the majority of our time there and
let's round you out by also helping you
understand a couple of really important
things in life that you're not good at
to you know stretch your neural muscles
and how help you develop and grow and do
a good well-rounded human being but it's
a crazy different approach to school
because I I think that my what I want is
for my children to fall in love with
learning so my son is a beekeeper and
he's got bees and he's got a mentor that
helps him figure out that whole thing
because he's nuts about that and I've
got another one of my boys that just
he's totally into architecture and wants
to build things so he gets projects
based on that my daughter wants to learn
Japanese so she's got you know a a
teacher in Japan that she Converses with
and you know we're going to Tokyo as a
family this summer and so you know part
of what we're doing on Fridays is just
rotating hey
what do our children need to fulfill
that custom curriculum for example my
kids are crazy about animals so we went
this last year we took the jet down to
Ecuador the Galapagos Islands rented a
private yacht for the week and just went
around the islands and got to like we
got to see all the crazy creatures the
Darwin saw and my kids loved it like it
was amazing we're on this private beach
and we've got sea lions swimming up to
us playing with us interacting putting
on a show as if they had been trained
you know by by some circus and it's like
I'll never forget that and so I you know
creating leaning into these custom
educational experiences is you know what
we hope will end up being the Hallmark
of their education
how much time do you think that you're
able to spend with your family versus at
work is it 50 50 is it 60 40 one way or
the other like how do you think about
that just based on the uh the days
yeah so pump I don't
I
I think there's a danger in time
blocking
and the danger of time blocking is that
sometimes it keeps us from actually
understanding the objective like I
remember I took my family to Disneyland
you know when my kids were young and I
was doing what I thought a good parent
should my wife and I we drug these you
know by the afternoon they were crying I
was wrestling with them they were just
they were so done we were trying to get
our money's worth and at the end of the
entire day I'm I'm in the in the hotel
with my wife and her bedroom exhausted
and I just realized something
I didn't connect with any of my children
meaningfully once
but the truth is
I can sit down with any person including
my children
in less than one minute cause a tear to
drop just by connecting with their soul
and then from inspiration speaking into
them the greatness I see in them
I can create more meaning in one minute
than a whole day at Disneyland so when I
time block I'm I'm always asking what is
the objective because most objectives
are not a function of quantity of time
they're a function of quality of time
and so I feel like I maybe get you know
my hope is I'm just getting a lot more
done because I'm pausing to reflect on
what
like it's not about having two hours
together
it's what can I do in this moment
anything that is Meaningful is always
experienced in a moment it's not
experienced over over time per se and so
I'm constantly challenging the time
blocking and asking what what is
actually meaningful this morning when I
you know right before coming down here
I was um lying on my bed with my wife
and my daughter I had headphones on and
I was doing a private meditation to her
you know with really nice calming
soothing music
and I was asking her in this directed
process to look in a mirror and figure
out something that isn't working for her
that she'd like to give up because she's
struggling with a lot of of depression
right now and she said Dad I'm I'm
carrying this weight on my body that I
gained for a boy that likes bigger girls
and and I'm done with that boy and I
don't like myself this way and I said
great who would you want to have help
you release that she said my parents and
when she came out of that meditation I
looked at her and I said I Promise You
by tomorrow night your mom and I will
give you a plan that you love and we're
at your side and over the next few weeks
we'll help you do this
well there was a there was an emotional
exchange there that really only took
less than 10 minutes
it didn't it wasn't two hours of hanging
out together doing something else and so
I'm asking I'm always asking how do I
use this moment
to get the real objective what is the
maximum meaning what is the maximum good
what is the highest and best use of this
moment
and I I think that's how we can condense
a thousand meaningful lives into one is
just by being far more intentional and
present
question that you talk about this
there's a bunch of studies that recently
have come out about the impact on uh
young girls from social media and I
think that folks like you and I who uh
have daughters but also have had immense
benefit from social media There is
almost this kind of pro and con or this
trade-off that as a society we are
somewhat struggling with right it's this
amazing thing that allows people to
connect with their family and friends to
learn to benefit to build companies like
do all these awesome things and then
there's almost this dark side of it how
do you think about uh those pros and
cons or or if there is a trade-offs from
a society standpoint
so the last couple of months this same
daughter has been suicidal
and um in December she was in a mental
hospital to keep her safe and
it was the most difficult thing my wife
and I had ever been through
and when I came out of that I realized
all right God I
I literally as am a breakthrough
transformation artist people come to my
events to experience life-changing
breakthroughs but I as Dad don't get to
do that for my own daughter
and
um
I felt inspired I'm actually pursuing a
company right now where I want to create
an environment that is safe for children
to experience everything from the
internet and social media that they want
I'm not talking about filters filters
are problematic you filter out all the
bad and what gets left behind isn't good
and so we're talking about an uh you
know version of social media the
internet a browser where everything is
curated with family values so you could
set your kid loose and they wouldn't
experience the dark side and um that
company is uh right now deep in uh
vetting and research process and we
think we might be onto something so
imagine if your daughter could you know
if you actually look at the Dark Side of
social media the problem is is there the
science is now confirming the dopamine
hit of these kids who have accounts
they're posting and doing things because
they're literally determining their
self-worth from whether they are liked
and we know how cruel dude bro you and I
know how cruel people are with their
comments because they can be they can
literally be trolls that hide behind
keyboards and they're mean so I'm
creating a version that where I can
bring all the entertainment and
education from social media but it's not
about having an account or being liked
or being a Creator because there's
something that they want but there's
some dark side as well so we're trying
to figure out what to keep and what to
lose
um so with my own kids on their phones
literally even my 17 year old doesn't
have the internet you know on her own
she doesn't have her own social media
accounts it's super
I literally produced 2 000 pieces of
media a week that might that my team
will probably put out and my own kids
are restricted from social media heavily
because I don't trust it like the
Creator is a tick tock in China their
version of tick tock is educational
what they sent America is undermining
and hurting and weakening the fabric of
our society with this mental health
condition this Young Generation that
feels all this awkward social anxiety
they've been told to wear diapers on
their face mask up Social distance and
it's it's it's wrong so yeah this
generation definitely has some
challenges and for me
um I believe we have a really important
just cause to try to fix it and um right
now you know we might see later this
year the emergence of a company
um you know that can try to be a part of
the solution
you mentioned on Saturdays that's your
day what do you do on Saturday
uh you know I think that everyone's got
to have some type of system for
self-care
how and by the way that system is daily
but I also give myself permission once a
week where it's like maybe I want to go
snowboarding by myself
you know maybe I want to go hang out
with some of my friends like what does
Chris time look like and you know in my
world I actually don't need a ton of it
personally there's other people I know
that need loads of it I'm an extrovert I
like to be with human beings
um I feed off of that
um you know but this is where I just get
really clear on hey what will create the
most meaningful memories in my life
let's go do those things I got some
people coming in town I've I've got a
six by six apocalypse amounted a 50
caliber modus on it we're gonna go take
a bunch of tannerite and fruit and we're
gonna blow stuff up I've got a buddy of
mine who's bringing flamethrower and a
whole bunch of
um you know you know full automatics and
we're literally gonna go crate in the
desert this crazy custom experience and
just have fun blowing stuff up like
that's fun I enjoy that so yeah part of
Saturday is just asking hey how do I
rejuvenate me because the most important
person on this planet that I pour into
is not my wife
and it's not even God if I'm not okay
then no other relationship can be and so
um I don't I don't sacrifice myself for
the greater good or to even serve my
family because the most powerful way for
me to serve them is to make sure I'm
good and I think that's a principle that
all people need to get clear with which
is are you achieving balance in your
life are you do you like where you're
growing in every area that's important
to you my body's got to be growing to
sustain superhuman Health my finances
have to be growing my relationships with
each of my children my wife have to be
growing and if all that's going down
that's great but I can't do those things
well I can't optimize those if I'm not
taking care of myself and I'm an
advocate for people making sure that
that self-care is present in their life
on some daily level and then once in a
while for me it's weekly there's got to
be some other expression that is even
bigger
so a lot of things are going right today
um you've built this amazing system
you've been able to launch a bunch of
businesses you've been able to put
yourself in a position financially and
also from a self-discipline standpoint
to spend specific days doing specific
things with your family or work or
whatever what would you say is the exact
opposite end of the current situation
what was the darkest time in your life
what was the the biggest thing that you
faced where you felt like my business is
blowing up my relationship like
everything is caving in on me what was
that situation and how did you get to
the other side of it
yeah
um so I served a two-year Christian
Mission for my church as a 19 year old
no College before then so when I got
back at 21 I felt late to the game and
for whatever strange reason I really
felt inspired that I wanted to I didn't
want to do the 5-10 year dating game I
actually wanted to find my best friend
and on third day of college uh I found
my wife and we were married 10 months
later and um I sold her on this dream I
was going to be a doctor and I'm doing
all my pre-med classes and and after
failing chemistry for the second time I
gave up on that dream and I was scared
of what she'd think and I felt I
remember at that time in my life I was
the one paying for my schooling my wife
didn't want to go into debt so I had a
full-time job and like literally 18
credit hours and working full-time was
it was a lot and it was stressing me out
Max and after four months of deciding I
was gonna be a doctor I couldn't find a
major in college that I could connect
with I'm like you could be this director
of that company like 80 000 a year you
could be an educator make 30 000 a year
you could do this thing psychologists
make sixty thousand a year I was like
wow this sucks there's there's no money
in this whole college system and that's
when I started um trying to figure out I
got to find something outside the walls
of these universities that's going to
work for me
um but what kind of sucked is the job
that I had was a was a telemarketing job
I didn't enjoy it I just was sucking the
life out of me and even after just being
at this one day I'd been at work for
like an hour and I was like I do not
want to be here and so I went home
and it was early afternoon because I'd
done school from six to noon
and when I come home I I found my wife
in tears
and I was confused because this woman
I'd known for over a year now I'd never
seen her cry this way before
and I thought someone must have died
because she had her cheeks have been
stained with tears I could see them
under the tiny little Puck Light the
only light in this tiny 400 square foot
apartment it's a little hallway
and so when I finally had the courage to
ask what's wrong
she said Chris
we have tuition due in three weeks we
can't pay for it I'm thinking wait is
she stressing over going into debt is
that what's producing these tears that
doesn't add up and then she said Chris
we have rent to in five days and we
already spent this Friday's paycheck
and I was like oh
I don't know I don't know how I'm gonna
fix that
and then I found out why she was really
crying she had gone grocery shopping we
only literally kept five days of food in
our cabinets we were empty
she had put like I don't know 20 or 30
dollars worth of cheap Ramen and
groceries in the in the cart she went to
check out
and basically insufficient funds
and she got denied and the the clerk
told her that she couldn't take the food
unless she had another form of payment
she didn't
my wife
had been home already for a few hours
crying and literally hungry
and in that moment I was like oh my gosh
like I'm about to relive all of my
parents Financial nightmares where
they're constantly stressed and fighting
about money my entire childhood going up
and here we go this is it like my wife
is I suck as a human being I don't know
how to provide I'd let my best friend
down I feel like this big of a man
and
that was a really sucky moment for me
but it was also one where I made a
different decision too because I poured
a lot of negativity into my soul but I
also decided
I am going to do whatever
it takes
to never be in this situation again
and four and a half years I was
financially independent graduated
college quit my job never needed to work
ever again
I basically lit a fire a bonfire under
my ass my ass just changed everything
for me
and um I mean so that was that that was
definitely a key moment um but the one
that really probably felt like it was
going to destroy me was um 2000 2009 I
had an employee steal some money from me
she got caught and then wanted to get
back at me which was really weird and
went to the SEC and made up 93
complaints they went and did a full
investigation on my company it was a
14-month investigation I was not
emotionally equipped with hardly any
intelligence
um I'd never experienced anything like
that I learned how powerful this
governing body was and if they wanted to
they could shut me down and destroy me
literally someone could go to jail even
though we had done nothing wrong I
learned at the end of that my deposition
at the end of that 14-month Journey was
the worst day of my entire life
and I remember after that thinking oh my
gosh it doesn't matter how financially
successful I am
mentally I'm that's probably
not a PC word but I have zero emotional
intelligence I have like no coping
mechanisms without my coaches I am I'm
worthless I have to figure this out and
um what I did is I I challenged myself
to this is when I leaned hard into
mentorship spent a couple million
dollars paying coaches like Tony Robbins
and others to come into my world and
literally start pouring into me and
teaching the emotional intelligence
business intelligence I started leveling
up my body my health my relationships
and I said you know what I need to
fortify this man I need to become
something more than I've been
because if I go on to fulfill my mission
and purpose in life this regulatory
incident that'll be nothing compared to
what I'm probably gonna face in my
future and so you know for me I a lot of
people will take hardship pump and they
will
core negatively into themselves only and
they'll perceive everything as a failure
for me there's a handful of people that
go the opposite and they say you know
what I'm gonna take I'm gonna take this
horrible mire and I'm gonna consecrate
it and I'm gonna make myself something
better
and um that that's what I did with those
incidents in my life and have sense with
some of the others
you think very differently than most
people I think that's pretty obvious I
think you know that as well what kind of
content do you consume what books do you
read what movies do you watch what do
you watch on YouTube uh who do you
follow on Twitter like what would you
kind of characterize as the the content
that you're consuming on a day-to-day
basis
yeah I I I I would first just pass an
admonition I think you have to be
careful about books
um because there's a lot of people
there's these sayings leaders are
readers and and the more books you read
the smarter you're going to get and for
me I don't care about how much you
consume I care if I'm consuming the
right quality and if I'm acting on it
and so I've probably honestly read less
books in the last decade than a lot of
people out there I've probably read 100
books and of those hundred books
um for me I will slow down and ask if
it's the right book it's an inspired
book and it's and it's got the quality
for me I would rather slow down and
Implement and so for me you know I'm
always warning people be careful of just
getting so consumed in the reader game
my current strategy today is uh I I read
about an hour a day I do that on double
time audio books so it takes about 30
minutes it's the first thing that
happens between 4 AM and 4 30 and I
toggle always back and forth between two
books one is some level of personal
mental expansion personal development
minded book by some major thought leader
that I'm really connected with uh and
then the other one is usually some type
of business book and so every day I just
go back and forth between uh between
books and uh the moment I'm feeling
inspired the moment I'm I'm connecting I
pause and I allow my mind to work
instead of getting lost in someone
else's Mission and audio and so what
that does is it massively slows things
down but I believe that sometimes you
should go slower if you want to go
faster so that's kind of my strategy for
putting thoughts and ideas in my head
but it's also like nothing compared to
being in a mastermind
um I'm engaged at any moment in multiple
masterminds uh you know these These Days
often I actually don't pay to be in
masterminds I get you know I'm the one
that Keynotes or speaks at them so I
actually get to swim in a lot of really
cool ecosystems and when I'm there even
if I'm gonna be you know a main speaker
I always pause and put my student hat on
and just my goal is to take more notes
than anyone present and to get myself in
that inspired state where I'm just
writing
um I like multi-day events so if I go to
a three-day conference I usually want 10
to do takeaways that are inspired per
day so I do a four day conference I'm
gonna I'm gonna have 40 takeaways and
I'll book time in the next two weeks
after
to implement all 40 things so that a
month two three later when I get to the
next conference I didn't just learn
something and fail to implement I would
rather consume way less
and do way more rather than what most
people I think do which is consumaton
but then do very little with it
that I think makes a ton of sense if you
had to give yourself uh when you were
first starting out some advice what are
two or three things that you could have
told yourself and saved yourself a lot
of time pain and headache
uh
this is gonna be this is probably not
going to land or make a whole lot of
sense
um but the most valuable skill um I
believe in Mastery Gladwell says Malcolm
Gladwell you need 10 000 hours to master
something I don't think that's true I
think that every time you master
something else you truncate the time and
it gets faster and easier especially if
you go to source so um if you're going
to do entry-level amateur classes you're
going to read books sure it's going to
take four or five years to achieve ten
thousand dollars of Mastery on something
but if you go to source and you go right
to the top there's usually a shortcut
where in 50 hours or a couple hundred
hours you can hit Mastery especially if
you've mastered other things today that
I've mastered 21 different things
and if I could take one of them with me
to the very beginning
uh it's an odd skill I call it belief
breakthrough
and it is an emotional intelligence
skill to uncover the blind spots in your
belief system humans are operating under
10 000 Notions that they agree to be
true although most of them are not
that's what a belief is it is an idea
for example I'm smart and someone else
says well I'm dumb and someone says I'm
successful and someone says I'm a
failure someone says I'm too fat my
genes won't let me I'm not capable I
can't do it by the time we're all 16
years old we've heard can't literally 50
000 times from well-meaning parents that
are trying not to get you to touch the
stove or walk into the street and at
some point we become adults but as
adults when we can now say yes to
everything most of us are literally
operating under a a a perception and a
perspective of no and so um this skill
that I've developed with a lot of my
coaches is a it's a it's a mental
process where I would just every day I
ask what's the number one limiting
belief holding me back
a thought comes to mind I judge the crap
out of it and I replace it with
something Limitless instead of its
limited notion that skill
um I've practiced 6 500 times it is
Rewritten my entire mindset so
everything in here is positively
reinforced with of course that I can't
of course I can be president of the
United States if that was my mission and
purpose in life which by the way it's
not of course I can this of course I can
build a billion dollar company a
multi-billion dollar company one of my
companies working on is literally 100
billion dollar potential that's not
mentally scary as a number because I've
done breakthroughs to be okay with that
quantity and to be you know so
belief breakthrough is probably the most
it's like a master skill for me because
whatever you believe you can or can't
you're right it's your thinking that
makes it so we've all heard that and so
this is the skill I'd take back to the
very beginning and say Chris bro you
have to challenge your thoughts because
most of them are crap you've got to look
at them because if you operate under the
assumption they're true and they're not
you're not going to be able to
manipulate reality and produce the
results that you want that's probably
the biggest thing I'd take back yeah
it's great when you think of your life
how many of the people that you're
surrounded by now are uh friends from
childhood or people that you've known
for you know 10 20 30 years versus
people that uh are new but you've almost
uh sought out because they have specific
experience or they are you know in a
similar type of business like how do you
think about the balance between uh what
I think a lot of like childhood friends
that you've known for 20 30 years versus
maybe people you meet later in life but
they bring other value do you have any
kind of framework to Think Through uh in
your life specifically uh what that
balance is
I think that it is a natural
developmental process
to want to keep a small close group of
friends that you've known for a long
time and keep them close
those friends are holding you back
the question is the people you spend
time with are they growth minded or
fixed-minded 99 of this planet has a
fixed mindset that means that um you
know I take a look at my brothers today
beautiful souls great men they went to
college they decided their career what
they wanted to do and today you know 15
20 years later they're still doing those
things
and when I look at their lives they have
beautiful families they have
um you know they've got great careers
and they've done well and I would chalk
that up as what I would call a normal
life I think a lot of people want to
have a normal life
me personally I detest normal
I associate it with mediocrity it feels
like the opposite of fulfilling life's
purpose of growth
and um and I hate it and so
I've had to get comfortable being a
traveler through life letting people
move in and out freely and there was
definitely a time when I wanted to keep
certain family members and Friends real
close and
I haven't let go of all of them but most
of them you know they're not in my world
the way they used to be in the beginning
some of those people just don't get me
or they don't understand or they you
know I'm addicted to growth I'm addicted
to change I love it it like changes my
jam if I can find anything that will
make me a better human I'm going to
latch onto it and try to build a habit
around it
um and that's weird I I there's
definitely a group of people out there
that are built that way but most are not
so at some point I had to just be okay
letting go and just being okay with that
and so I you know on my side of the
family
um I got eight brothers and sisters my
parents live with me I take care of them
my siblings once or twice here will pop
into town we'll connect there's one of
them that I have a really deep
meaningful relationship with
um on my white side of the family she's
really close with her family we get to
see them a couple times a month they're
they're off you know half of them are
living locally in the area and we'll do
uh you know we'll travel together you
know once or you know you know I think
once every other year on some kind of
reunion thing together
um but honestly I don't spend a lot of
time with them uh the friends that I
spend my time with today and right now
there's five couples that I spend a lot
of time with for my wife and I in our
friend Circle they're all entrepreneurs
for the most part
um we put on literally every month
growth night where we're gamifying the
game of how are we growing and
developing most of them are getting on
stage with me in eight weeks for this
physique competition uh the ladies are
doing bikini for the most part the men
are doing physique competition
um we go to conferences together we
travel together we're going to isolator
this year together and I found a tribe
of people that I can grow with and then
outside of that in my family you know
that I have my own masterminds that I
run where I'm connecting with like Ultra
like-minded people that believe in that
just cause profitability the game of
growth their health everything
and uh that's kind of what my my
universe looks like
when you think about your life today
um is there a word that you would use to
describe it
like just as close growth yeah I think
growth is a spiritual game I think it's
the game of life I think it's the one
that matters the most and and um this
probably sound highly judgmental but
when I evaluate humans not judge but
when I evaluate and assess behavior
um what I'm looking for is whether they
whether they resist growing or whether
they lean fully into it and most don't
um and I lead a tribe of people that are
trying to figure that game out and they
want more of that in their life
um
so yeah growth is is I think at the
center
when you think of your life
um one of the other things that a lot of
entrepreneurs feel is
um interesting and inspiring is just to
see how much growth someone can actually
experience if you go all the way back
you told the story of uh you know when
your wife went to the grocery store the
card was declined and it was this you
know somewhat embarrassing but just kind
of a moment that really shook you and
said hey you have to change
when you think today how much money do
you make how much are you able to invest
every year like how do you think about
your financial portfolio what what
information are you comfortable sharing
there that can kind of help people see
like hey you can go from not having
anything right and kind of being in this
really bad situations like here is what
is possible
so
I look at Health First and um when I got
married I would say I was relatively fit
but I came from a very unhealthy family
diabetes was always a fear heart attack
stroke
um and so I was trying to make Fitness
my game and I'll go to the gym five to
six times a week and I couldn't figure
out the result my body was usually 30 40
50 pounds overweight pencil necked
and um it was probably 10 11 years ago I
got some specific Health coaching and I
was just like I I hate that I feel like
I've wasted a decade of my life like
mistaking movement for achievement
because every day go to the gym and I
move and I am not getting the outcome
I'm clearly doing something wrong
and so I went heavy into belief
breakthrough work and hiring health
coaches and within six months completely
transformed my life
and haven't been back since like I carry
my trophy with me every year my body
right currently is a little faster a
little stronger longevity is connected
to your VO2 levels and your muscular
term that's it those two things
determine the length of life I want to
be 140 years old and I take care of my
body with the assumption that I am going
to be that's what I'm programming and
signaling my genes and my body to do and
produce in a 25 minute meditation I do
every single day so my health today I
now carry a six-pack with me all the
time and every year I'm a little more
muscular I'm a little less fat and I do
that for me in the beginning it was like
it was vanity I I wanted to uphold a
certain image I wanted to look good
naked I don't really care so much about
that right now my my health is my wealth
and so that's a huge change my marriage
21 years and honestly the first five
years sucked my wife and I were not on
the same page we married our offices for
a reason I was Mr change and she was Mr
don't move Mrs and um so she was I was
like morphogenesis she was homeostasis
and it took us years to figure out how
to advocate for each other and support
each other and you know in the last
decade we have built an incredible
marriage everything I want to get
everything she wants she gets and we
have a system for verifying that every
single day that's one of our top
priorities one of our standards whatever
you want I want it more for you than you
want it yourself
you know so literally going from kind of
in the dumps honestly with just we don't
get the marriage game to where we're at
today's beautiful thing then of course
financially
um
there's games
that I used to play I spent way too long
in the real estate game
I was stuck as an operator most
entrepreneurs are it's just like well
this is my identity and this is who I am
this is my baby and like women make
babies and then they get attached to
them for 18 years frankly for the rest
of their lives they have all this
oxytocin and chemistry there's so it's
like I'll die for my baby I'll do
anything for my baby but men that are
entrepreneurs and females when you
create something like a business that's
also like a baby this and and so we get
really attached to it and um Detachment
has been a beautiful process for me to
finally get to the point where I'm like
wait
create it and then the real measure of
success is not how much time you put
into it it's the maximum value you
create in the world while reclaiming
maximum time for you so you can move on
Leverage the life experience and do
something bigger
so if you were to look at me financially
you know six seven years ago I was still
only the the real estate guy pump and so
sure my net worth like is on a great
trajectory with all those doors that I
buy
um but most of what I do is a Buy and
Hold strategy which means there's
limited cash flow and huge growth like a
single property
over 20 years at a 34 average Roi turns
into 17.4 million dollars and every day
I I form a partnership with someone in
the world that says here's my 401k or My
Equity or my home equity let me dump it
in let's buy a house or two because in
20 years I want to wake up and be
surprised by 10 20 30 50 100 million
dollars and so I build portfolios with
people when I finally gave myself
permission to not be the operator
that's when I started my second business
and within a year I learned it should be
10 and then it should be way more than
that
so
um yeah I mean like how vulnerable am I
willing to be
um
I'll put it to you this way my goal
since
January 15 2009 was to be a billionaire
and right now sometime end of 2023 or
mid-2024
I believe that's when that's going to
happen
and uh in my lifetime I want to be a
trillionaire like I'm like I have the
ability to grow and use the time that I
set aside for this and I'm just going to
keep multiplying wealth and uh
and if I have 104 years on this planet
totally doable because you know my wife
and I we put a lot of effort into our
foundation that's where we find a lot of
our meaningful time together and uh
right now I want to just pour billions
of dollars into that because that's the
Legacy that continues when we're not
here and and the work that it does is it
changed lives it saves lives it's it's
hugely impactful so that's kind of the
core motivation of just why more well it
doesn't really change my lifestyle much
but it sure can for a lot of other
people
that is a a beautiful place to end Chris
where can we send people to find you on
the internet uh find the content that
you're producing the books that you've
written or any of the other things that
you're doing
so I've got a whole bunch of gifts for
anyone that's listened today if you feel
like there's something you want to
explore more you can go to
freewealthgift.com
and what I did there is I put multiple
giveaways I put some of my books I I put
free consultations or just a literally
even free event tickets so instead of
paying 1500 for an event literally you
can come as my guest so
um free wealthgift.com is where someone
could go and learn more but other than
that you just
Google my names gotta spell it right
it's Chris with a K and chrome with the
K and uh and I'm I'm on all the
different platforms so yeah feel free to
connect and grab some of those gifts
Chris I appreciate it so much I've
learned a lot from you today uh I think
there's a lot of people out there who uh
who could take your message and
implement it in their life and I
appreciate you taking the time to have
this conversation and hopefully we'll do
it again in the future
appreciate you Palm thank you